let's talk about the number one top
nutrient deficiency in rotator cuff
injuries and a lot of other joint
injuries as well okay this deficiency is
actually a mineral deficiency which i'm
going to get to but i want to give you
just a very brief overview of the
rotator cuff muscles okay
so here's the arm joint right here
here's the back
part okay of your shoulder
and this is the front part right here
here's the clavicle so there's really
four muscles involved with the rotator
cuff it's called sits okay you have this
top muscle right here
that lifts your arm up right here it's
called the supraspinatus
then you have the
infraspinatus it's below this spine
right here and then right below that you
have this teres minor muscle
and then on the inside you have the
subscapularis
so those are the four rotator cuff
muscles
all right now there's a lot of
information we can talk about the
rotator cuffs but a lot of it's not
important
um it's just history i want to talk
primarily about the important things you
need to know about your rotator cuff
muscles now
up to 94
of all
treatments to the rotator cuff
um involve
more treatment because of recurrent
repairs and failures so in other words
it doesn't have a really good success
rate okay so this is why i'm doing this
video to give you another solution that
can
help with your concurrent treatment now
the next most important thing to know is
that the majority of rotator cuff
problems are related to the tendon not
the muscle okay but the tendons
so tendons connect from muscle to bone
ligaments connect bone to bone but
tendons go from the muscle
to the bone and these ligaments are
incredibly strong but they are
susceptible to
issues okay
a couple of the things you need to know
um tendons have a very poor blood supply
and so when they get injured
they don't heal like muscles do that
have a large blood supply
and when you injure a tendon
you get a
lowered amount of oxygen it's called
hypoxia and that triggers something else
which i don't want to get into the
complexities of but it triggers some new
blood supply to that
tendon okay but there's an interesting
paradox that happens so even though this
hypoxic condition
creates more blood supply which is
supposed to increase more oxygen and
nutrients
it actually
doesn't there still seems to be this
persistent hypoxic state and if you look
a little bit deeper into that
what occurs when you have this injury is
you have this
this leaky tendon it starts leaking very
similar to leaky gut so you have this
loss of oxygen and loss of
nutrients the other point about these
tendons when they get injured is you
don't really see inflammation going on
so it's not really an inflamed
tendon okay that's not what's happening
you definitely have pain and things like
that
but you don't necessarily have
inflammation the other thing you need to
know about the tendons is they heal
with disorganized tissue which is scar
tissue uh they don't heal with the
normal
nice fibers that are interwoven and keep
things nice and strong they heal with
basically scar tissue as its survival
mechanism just to patch it up with some
scar tissue and the problem with that
long term is it heals in a weakened
state and so you may find that with
regardless of what treatment you have
it's never going to be as strong as it
was and that's with my case too i
injured this shoulder fractured it and
this elbow two separate injuries
and man i've worked this thing for so
long x-rays etc there's a little bit of
tiny bit of arthritis but it's really uh
from the injury and
so there are some things you can do to
maximize the strength but as far as it
coming back 100
uh that's probably not going to happen
and the other two things you don't want
to do is apply cold to a rotator cuff
injury now it might decrease pain but it
actually gets rid of all the things that
are necessary to come to bring into the
healing also rest is not the best idea
as well because with rest you just have
more scar tissue the best thing is to
keep it
moving as much as possible at your level
okay so now i'm not talking about a
complete tear i'm not talking about that
i'm talking about trauma to the tendon
as well so now the question is what
should you do okay if there's just
arthritis in your shoulder and there's
not an actual tear of your rotator cuff
tendons hanging is one of the best
stretches okay with an overhead bar
but if there's trauma to the tendon
hanging might not be a good idea
isometric exercises are really good for
tendon problems
because you're not creating this motion
but you are stimulating the area and
it's really good for pain
vitamin d is very very important not the
most important one but this will
decrease inflammation vitamin c is also
necessary for collagen repair okay not
the most important nutrient but
important
sufficient amino acids from protein very
important but not the most important i
already mentioned this keeping things
moving on a regular basis is very very
important in rehabbing and also
eccentric exercise i've done a video on
this
this is where you kind of reverse the
exercise so if you're going to do some
type of motion where you're contracting
the muscles and you're shortening the
muscles
that would be not this okay this is
elongating the muscles
i will put some links down below but the
most important nutrient okay for
rehabbing a tendon is manganese okay now
why would a manganese deficiency
slow down your healing of tendons
because manganese is not only a powerful
antioxidant so this enzyme right here
which is completely dependent on
manganese
has its highest concentration in your
tendons okay and then this turns into
this enzyme which specifically regulates
the repair of your enzyme and there's
another enzyme that manganese is
involved with which has everything to do
with collagen formation so if you're
deficient in manganese okay which a lot
of people are
you're going to have a heck of a time
keeping your tendons strong you're going
to have a heck of a time rehabbing and
repairing your tendons so
manganese is the most important
trace mineral
for strengthening your tendons as well
as your ligaments that's why in my
clinic i used to use it for low back
pain especially if there's a disc
involved but for rotator cuff it's hands
down it's one of the best trace minerals
now if you look up the source of where
you get manganese from they'll say whole
grains legumes
vegetables things like that but the
problem with whole grains is the phytic
acid
and other
anti-nutrients that will block the
absorption of manganese so the best
source of manganese is
shellfish okay clams
mussels
other types of shellfish if you're going
to take it as a supplement i would take
about 200
milligrams okay for a period of time
maybe for a month and then i would back
off and i probably wouldn't take it i
would try to focus on getting it from
the food
now the um
the ai for
manganese that's the adequate intake
amount so this represents a figure
that gives you a certain amount to
prevent a deficiency but nothing to do
with maintaining health of that nutrient
but just to prevent a deficiency is like
2.3 milligrams that's a joke it's so
small
the other thing you need to know is when
you take statins
steroids
and
antibiotics specifically cipro
all three of these types of medications
can stop the healing of a damaged tendon
if you haven't seen this video on
inflammation i think you should check it
out right here
you